one other anime I want to talk about
which I think is being holy [__] so
underappreciated right now is a new
Gundam oh okay the new it's uh it's
weird seeing just the dichotomy between
how popular and how well advertised it
is here in Japan yeah and just how under
watched it is with like Western
audiences you go to like people are
scared of Gundam yeah you go to like the
my anime list page and you scroll down
of like all of like the fall anime
seasons and Gundams like right near the
bottom I'm like how the [__] is a show
this good that's delivering this hard
that close to the bottom in terms like
popularity yeah it's it's weird right
because like I think for a lot of people
Gundam is just like this thing that's
been around for [__] you know yeah
almost half a century at this point
right it's super intimidating it's
intimidating because like people know
the name yeah but so few have actually
sat down and like even watched half of
the [__] that's come out of the Gundam
Universe yeah yeah and so like when you
see a new Gundam immediately you just
think oh well I do want to watch it it
looks cool but that would mean I have to
go all the way back and watch everything
and obviously you don't have to right
you don't have to no absolutely but it's
kind of like so there's I'm gonna sound
like that person again uh so there's
like separates there's like several
different timelines in Gundam and so
there's one main timeline that's kind of
like the MCU where it goes all the way
yeah kind of except things are in
chronological order right yeah yeah
um yeah so we go and that timeline goes
all the way to the very very first
Gundam that was made in like 1970 or
something and I I haven't watched any of
those Gundams because I'm that guy who
wants to really immerse myself and know
every little Easter egg and stuff like
that so in order for me to enjoy some
some Gundams like for example Gundam
unicorn or
um you know Thunderball Gundam Hathaway
uh I would need to go all the way back
to the beginning to
gets the full appreciation of everything
going on you don't need to like I'm not
saying you need to this is a me thing
you know I've been trying for years like
hiding myself up to be like all right
this is the day yeah where I start my
Gundam journey and then when I look at
the list I'm just like
maybe next week yeah exactly and then
there are certain other Gundams that are
just separate from this main timeline
which are much more let's say newbie
friendly stuff like Gundam Wing Gundam
Double O
uh what was the desert Gundam [__]
not seed
um I call it Gundam space Africa because
that's basically what it is
do you know what I'm talking about you
[__] know what I'm gonna explain
space Africa to me
oh [__] this is this is this is gonna it
speaks Africa space Africa Gundam
original shows uh because it was the
last newbie friendly Gundam it's like
you can tell me that I don't need to
watch any other Gundam but something in
my brain just will not allow me to watch
it and not be like I have I I I this
there's more yeah what's the last gun
you watched that's why you've mentioned
this before I haven't watched anything
yeah I watched like one episode of that
and then I got scared and I was like no
I'm watching anymore
uh I'm I was like it's not iron blood at
all first
yeah okay it's scary all right let me
sell you on like the new gun which is
Gundam the witch from Mercury
um so it's a new Gundam so it's like you
you know I want interaction with this
with the show at least when I've heard
of it the last time I ever heard
anything about it was when we were in
the car to film with uh Charlie right
was critical and the guy who picked us
up was talking about it yeah oh yeah I
just remember sitting there he's like
yeah it's really well actually that's
not what he sounds like this but he's
like it's just cool they have like uh
lesbians in this one and I was like what
yeah what oh yeah the main girls are
like a couple right yeah that was all I
heard about is this guy's like I just
like the it's like a lesbian this time
I'm like what I mean I mean they do like
it's it's kind of it's kind of got
lesbians in it I guess yeah I don't know
if that's true that's what he said and I
was like I mean I mean I mean it's
like it's like lesbian or like it's like
Yuri in the same way as like most other
Yuri shows where it's just like there's
just two girls they're just really
really get along they're just really
good friends they're just really good
friends like licorice recoil they're
just like the main two girls they're
just they're just really really good
friends are they actually gay I'll never
tell
we all never tell we'll just hint at it
yeah
um that's up to you yeah
artist but um no so yeah this is a
completely newbie friendly Gundam so you
can get into this knowing nothing about
Gundam I think it's designed that way as
well
um and one thing that Gundam has always
been like one of the main selling points
about Gundam has always been the
politics right and normally a lot of
times it's been about the politics of
War right you have two warring Nations
and that's been a lot of like Mecca in
general uh what I've really liked about
um Gundam the witch from Mercury is that
it focuses more on like corporate
politics so it's set in this world where
this whole corporation like Mega
Corporation control was basically every
kind of giant robot every Mecca that's
made survival huh Google so Google
[__] like imagine if like Elon Musk
yes
imagine if Amazon took over the world
which they're basically and just start
like had a monopoly on giant robots okay
that would be this like Corporation
right and within this Corporation
there's like Branch companies that Vie
for power within this one giant Mega
Corporation right and obviously every
every different every different branch
companies makes different types of giant
robots and different meccas and stuff
like that
um and obviously there's a special kind
of robot called Gundams using gunned
technology that obviously is like super
[__] op and stuff like that
um and but it got so op that it's uh
they banned the technology in this
company by kind of like killing everyone
off and stuff like [__] yeah you know
you could have just like made them
unemployed but yeah yeah yeah yeah
exactly let's take it out Men In Black
though yeah yeah exactly and I've really
I really liked the fact that they didn't
go down the you know they didn't just go
down the wall routes again because I I
found I found like
Gundam when I see Gundam I see like
another War Story I'm like okay I've
seen this I've seen it before in fact
I've seen it so many [__] times
before uh but just seeing them still
have a heavy a show like Stephen
politics but just shift it into like
corporate politics and just like vying
for like power within this big Mecca
Corporation I thought yeah that was that
was that was a that's a really
interesting take like seeing uh like one
scene that stands out to me is like one
of the main characters uh one of the
main girls has to like pitch this
company idea to all of like these Mega
corporations so it's all the leaders of
all the branch companies be like please
invest in my company we are going to
make all these they basically do a pit
like like a [__] uh Shark Tank
investor pitch just with [__] giant
robots and Gundam and I'm like this is
this is actually pretty cool because
that's an enriched that's an original
take on Gundam yeah
um
like normal story points so like yeah uh
Shark Tank
shark tank with Max uh
and it's just like it's just a lot of
these Branch companies like trying to
sabotage each other
um and try and make like the best giant
robots uh they can uh it's written by
the same person who wrote Code Geass as
well okay so it's got a bit of like high
school hijinks in it but it's that's
what you expect
why the [__] is that high school this is
60 less excited to watch it because the
English media sound sick and then you're
like by the way there I I did need to
mention that because you know they they
needed to add giant robots fighting
somehow you know because it's a [__]
high school huh what high school uh it's
a high school where basically it's ice
it's like a business
it's a privileged High School where
daughters and sons of all like the
leaders of all these Mega corporations
kind of like send send their send their
kids to this one school and how they
settle any dispute in the school is by
like it's by setting a jewel
they said we should bring that yeah
that's that's how this that's how the
term starts off is that uh one of the
girls is betrothed to one of the uh kids
and betrothed to one of the kids in one
of the others yeah uh and then there's
this main girl who's like comes from
like a peasant family you know like poor
girl and she just like me for she uh she
challenges the guy to a drool and he and
by winning the jewel uh she inadversely
also means that the girl the other girl
is betrothed to her as well because
that's the rules of the jewel that will
set like are they like physical Jewels
or are they like how many stocks and
bonds can I buy anything
that's that's the physical like giant
robot Jewels all right yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah okay yeah I feel like they
added that because they're like we can't
make a entire Gundam just on stocks
[__] we need to add giant robot fights
in this somehow I feel like Gundam fans
will though they will watch stuff as
long as you say they're trading robots I
think Gundam fans are like okay AI model
has Tesla technology
but honestly it's uh giant robot flights
[__] amazing it's one of the
prettiest looking Mecca shows I've seen
in a long time
um production values off the scale but
also I think more people need to watch
it and I think people yeah are scared
just because it's Gundam and I'm just
like just [__] watch it if they're if
you ever have been curious about Gundams
or if you've it's just been a long time
since you've watched a giant robot show
I think this is like the perfect show
for that yeah I think I think another
big reason why people are scared to get
into Gundam is as you said like it's a
lot of them are kind of like the same
themes and like the same story just like
repackage right like as much as I like
really enjoyed like iron blooded orphans
I will admit I watch and I was just like
Yep this is a Gundam show it's it's yeah
I think that's also the same reason why
I never got as invested in 86 as I
thought I should have I mean I know
Europeans
I got tried
yeah I mean I I enjoyed 86 but like just
it was just seeing like another Mecca
show about war and I'm just like okay
I've seen this before right I've seen
it's like different flavors of the same
thing and not not saying that that's a
bad thing but it's just like a story
that I've seen before so I really
appreciated the gun in the wish Mercury
like just taking like a different route
two giant robots but still making it
political which is one thing I've always
the question is it cannon with the
entire like universe or is it no it's
not yeah it's it's it's so in separate
which is why I say it's like you can
jump on right as a newbie knowing
nothing about Gundam right because it's
got nothing to do with it I'll be honest
I probably won't watch that yeah
I saw like as soon as I mentioned High
School the lights from Connor's eyes
just like [__]
I was already kind of like it sounds
okay and then you mentioned that I'm
like no I'm I'm done I don't know I
don't want to watch that